gibt es schon längst einen kontakt zu
aliens und wir wissen es nur noch nicht
einiges spricht dafür dass
außerirdische und zumindestens
beobachten ein halion satellit im
erdorbit gilt als wahrscheinlichstes
szenario jedenfalls wenn man nach dem
kanadier alan traf gehen und der
deutsche kultur soziologe michael
schätzle hält sogar eine erste
kontaktaufnahme für möglich und zwar
eine die bereits stattgefunden hat die
zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
es gibt bekanntes bekannteste dinge von
denen wir wissen dass wir wissen wir
wissen auch dass es bekannte unbekannte
gibt das heißt wir wissen es gibt dinge
die wir nicht wissen aber es gibt auch
unbekannte unbekannte dinge also von
denen wir nicht wissen dass sie nicht
wissen
diese denkwürdige anmerkung stammt vom
ehemaligen amerikanischen
verteidigungsminister donald rumsfeld
und er hat nicht so ganz unrecht und
gerade beim thema aliens gibt es eine
menge dass wir nicht wissen und
wissenschaftler sind sich sicher dass
wir vieles nicht wissen und auch nicht
wissen dass wir es nicht wissen
allerdings kann man das ändern und das
unwissen über das was wir nicht wissen
etwas verringert denn es ist eben nicht
so dafür über den ersten kontakt mit
aliens rein gar nicht wissen wenn wir
ein paar grundannahmen durchdenken dann
wissen wir sogar eine menge darunter der
ansatz von michael schätzle ist dabei
sehr interessant dem kultursoziologe er
hat nämlich einige rahmenbedingungen
zum erstkontakt durchdacht die
hellhörig machen er geht davon aus dass
art und ort des kontaktes die
kollektiven psychischen projektionen auf
die aliens aber wenn wir zum beispiel
für böse halten weil wir hässlich
sind und die möglichkeit der
geheimhaltung entscheidend für die
folgen eines erstkontakte sind und die
folgen können dramatisch sein dass
absolute horror szenario wäre ihm nach
eine erste begegnung hier auf der erde
mit alien von denen wir uns bedroht
fühlen es wurde sofort zur weltweiten
massenpanik kommen und das vollkommen
unabhängig von den absichten der
außerirdischen in der folge würde sich
bei entsprechender technischer und
kultureller überlegenheit ein
verhältnis von entdecker und entdeckten
bilden die zur kompletten zerstörung
unserer kultur und wissenschaft führen
würde
wir wären unmündige unwissenden
elefanten die von der überlegenen spät
ist an die hand genau
werden würden und das geschieht ganz
unabhängig davon ob die außerirdischen
uns unterwerfen wollen oder nicht die
konsequenzen wären sie uns in jedem
fall absolut dramatisch zetsche wünscht
sich der biber keinen kontakt oder
zumindest ein über weite distanzen oder
an einem neutralen ort aber in jedem
fall nicht auf der erde deshalb geht
aber auch davon aus dass wenn es ihn
gegeben haben sollte er tatsächlich von
dem jeweiligen land geheim gehalten
wurde weil die folge neben unabsehbar
wären zwar sei er kein anhänger von
verschwörungstheorien aber wenn eine
gemeinschaft wie zum beispiel beim bau
der atombombe vom nutzen der
geheimhaltung überzeugt ist dann
könnte ein solches wissen auch über
jahre verborgen werden bei der atombombe
hat es trotz tausender mitwisser
geklappt allerdings müssen eben alle
mitglieder dieser gemeinschaft vom
positiven nutzen überzeugt sein jetzt
noch mal zurück zu allen taft er hat
ein team von psychologen um sich
geschart und sogar eine einladung an
aliens im netz veröffentlicht
allerdings hat er die antwort nicht mehr
erlebte er 2012 gestorben und ehrlich
gesagt war auch pädagoge hat aber nicht
den optimalen wissenschaftlichen
bäckern aber er hatte eigentlich eine
ganz vernünftige idee wenn es
außerirdisches leben im weltall gibt
dann muss es zivilisationen geben die
unsere haushoch überlegen sind der
grund unsere erde ist etwa 4 6
milliarden jahre als das universum ist
aber exakt dreimal so alt mit 13,8
milliarden jahren es muss also viel
ältere gewohnte planeten geben mit
dementsprechend weiter entwickelten
zivilisation
jetzt gibt es eigentlich nur ein paar
mögliche szenarien warum wir keinen
kontakt zu ihnen haben erstens es gibt
zu viele spezies im universum wirbeln
ziemlich uninteressant sie haben einfach
kein interesse an uns zweitens sie
beobachten uns bereit und haben einen
satelliten in der erdumlaufbahn oder
irgendwo im system ein objekt das so
klein ist dass wir es einfach nicht
entdecken
drittens der kontakt hat bereits
stattgefunden und wird aber geheim
gehalten weil die von michael schätzle
geschilderten gefahren drohen oder last
but not least viertens es ist wie beim
raumschiff enterprise wenn wir den warp
antrieb erfunden haben nehmen die
außerirdischen kontakt mit uns auf weil
wir sie dann auch probleme
erreichen können wir wissen also eine
ganze menge über den erstkontakt nur
nicht welche der varianten tatsächlich
wirklichkeit wird
oder ist ja sobald es neue erkenntnisse
gibt werden ist natürlich hier erfahren
sollte mir dafür hier ein abo aufsaugen
vergesse ich den glocken nur dann
verpasst er kein video hier geht es
weiter mit den gefahren die davon
ausgehen wenn wir aliens und wichtig zu
uns locken oder bereits gelockt haben
davor warnt michael schätzle nämlich
und da haben wir dann schon eine menge
mist gebaut und welchen dass sie dem
video und ansonsten bestand bleibt dran